ce n'est pas encore une carte postale
mais c'est un petit miracle qui vaut le
détour plantés sur 12 hectares et après
deux ans et demi d'efforts pascal aux
piles céréaliers vie enfin son rêve
cultiver la lavande sur une terre à
première vue peu exploitables senneterre
qu'une faible potentiel en en culture
traditionnelle en cultures
conventionnelles
donc j'ai toujours aimé les fleurs je me
suis dit pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
transformer ce champ avec un faible
potentiel en terre de lavande et en plus
on est alors on nous parle beaucoup du
réchauffement climatique donc peut-être
que c'est une solution pour le
réchauffement climatique de produire des
déserts bapt qui demande très peu d'eau
et beaucoup de soleil pour réussir son
pari pascal opi s'est rendu dans la
terre promise de la lavande à valensole
dans les alpes de haute provence pour
s'y former et acheter des plants de
lavande et pour sa récolte oublier la
faucille il a investi dans cette machine
artisanale
de ratons à l'avant alors des râteaux
qui peuvent être en plastique ou en fer
qui relève les brins de lavande tomber
et puis ensuite vous avez un système qui
coupe et puis un système qui charge et
après une fois que c'est dans la
l'autochargeuse il ya un déchargement
automatique qui se fait à l'endroit où
vous voulez bien des charges est
distillée par la suite en huiles
essentielles notre céréaliers espère
produire 300 litres d'ici la fin du mois
d'août une lavande made in chair qui a
déjà attiré l'oeil des offices de
tourisme et des particuliers